this video with me possible by curiosity
stream watch over 2400 documentaries for
free for a month at curiosity stream
calm / Wendover private jets represent
an inconceivable level of opulence if
the average American were to spend their
entire year salary to charter a
Gulfstream g550 from New York they would
just barely make it to Utah and yet
there's a class of people who use these
planes to fly not just from New York to
Utah but rather routes like New York to
Beijing there's a class of people who
will spend tens or hundreds of thousands
of dollars on just one single flight now
there are a few reasons this is strange
beyond just the sheer price of things
chartering that Gulfstream from London
to Dubai for example you'd end up paying
about fifty five thousand dollars a
track rate meanwhile if you were to fly
Emirates first class which is just if
not more opulent you could fly between
the cities 20 times for the same price
which even stranger about this kind of
expense is that businesses which are
intended to maximize profits for their
shareholders or able to justify this
enormous expense as worthwhile so when
is it that paying eight thousand dollars
or more an hour to fly makes money
there's a pretty simple way of figuring
this out out of the 8760 hours in the
year the average CEO works two thousand
seven hundred and sixteen of them for a
CEO that's paid 1 million dollars a year
that makes an hour of their time or 368
dollars among America's largest
companies though the average CEO earns
15.6 million that makes their hour worth
five thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars for the most part though private
jets fly about these same speed as
commercial planes so in flying a route
like London to Dubai the time savings
come at the airports on each end it
comes from being able to arrive get on a
plane and fly rather than having to
navigate one's way through a busy
terminal for a fixed flight time but
still flying private diverse commercial
from London to Dubai would say if at
most about three hours in Airport time
with the cost of fifty five thousand
dollars for the flight that would mean
the CEOs time would have to be worth
eighteen thousand three hundred dollars
per hour that wouldn't be true until
they earned fifty million dollars a year
a salary earned only by the upper
echelon of CEOs but the truth is that
the most part private jets do not make
economic sense when flying routes with
plenty of commercial service like London
to Dubai one of the larger corporate jet
fleets out there belongs to Walmart now
this might come as a surprise
considering that this is a company so
focused on keeping costs low
you see Walmart is headquartered in
Bentonville Arkansas a relatively small
city of 50,000 the airport does have a
surprising amount of service for such a
small city with flights all the way to
Los Angeles and New York largely propped
up by the company's traffic before the
higher ups commercial doesn't cut it
that's why the company has a fleet of 20
corporate jets the largest of any
American company these are most
frequently flown by the companies a
regional vice president who are in
charge of a specific area of the country
and will have to make frequent store
visits within this region the company
apparently has a goal that nobody spends
a night away from Venton ville they want
as many trips as possible three day
trips now let's say that one of these
executive vice presidents needs to make
a trip to three stores one in Rock
Springs Wyoming one in Spokane
Washington and the last in Great Falls
Montana
getting to Rock Springs requires a seven
hour itinerary through Denver that would
get this executive in at 9:30 p.m.
therefore already requiring an overnight
stop then the next day they would do
their store visit in the morning and as
there are only two flights a day from
Rock Springs they would have to wait
until 4:50 p.m. to catch a flight back
to Denver then another one to Spokane
getting in at 8:30 p.m. local time
therefore requiring another overnight
stop the next morning they would do
their site visit but once again flight
schedules dictate that the first
itinerary to Great Falls would leave at
5:05 p.m. through Salt Lake City getting
in at 10:04 p.m. local time thereby
requiring another overnight stop
following the next morning store visit
this executive would catch a noon flight
to Denver and after a 3-hour layover
another to finally get into Bentonville
at 8:00 p.m. these three store visits
would therefore take up to four whole
working days but what if this executive
flew private leaving at 9:00 a.m. the
first flight director Rock Springs would
take an hour and 45 minutes getting in
with the hours time change at 9:45
local time after a two-hour store visit
the plane would take off again at 11:45
a.m. flying an hour and 15 minutes to
Spokane getting in at noon local time
after another two hours tour visit the
plane would take off at 2:00 p.m. for a
quick 45-minute flight to Great Falls
getting in at 3:45 p.m. local time a
very final two hours at this store the
plane would take off its final time at
5:45 p.m. bound for Bentonville 2 hours
and 15 minutes of flight time later it
would land at 9 p.m. local time exactly
12 hours after leaving what was a
four-day trip on commercial flights
becomes a day trip on private and that's
why Wal Mart decided private jets are
worth it for them it's all about valuing
the time of their employees and they've
determined that even for the relatively
low level vice-presidents their time is
valuable enough that it's worth flying
them private for example one of the
aircraft Walmart owns and operates is
the Learjet 45 it cost the company about
$4 per mile to operate this aircraft
including crew fuel insurance
maintenance and all other variable costs
therefore the 2900 miles flown on that
day trip to the northeast would cost
them about eleven thousand six hundred
dollars saving three days that places a
value of three thousand nine hundred
dollars per day which means that
assuming the executive onboard works
every single one of those 260 workdays
per year they would have to make almost
exactly 1 million dollars per year for
this private jet ride to be worth it to
Walmart an amount within the realm of
possibility for upper management at such
a large company of course that's not
factoring in the alternative options
Hotel food and airline transport costs
which would likely sum into the
thousands
and it's also assuming there's just one
passenger if the plane were to be filled
to its maximum capacity of nine each
passenger would only need to be paid one
hundred and eleven thousand dollars per
year for the expense to be worth it to
the company which is less than an
average Walmart store manager makes now
there's one other case where private
jets can make economic sense over flying
commercial let's say Walmart was looking
to expand into the Philippines flying
business class it would cost a minimum
of five thousand dollars per person
require three stops and take over twenty
six hours to get from Bentonville to
Manila flying private though a
long-range jet like the Bombardier
global 7500 could
make it there non-stop in just 15 hours
carrying 19 of the company's top
executives since the company does not
own this type of jet would likely
charter one at a cost of about $10,000
an hour or 150,000 dollars for the trip
well the cost of commercial airfare is
less than this assuming the CEO who
makes twenty four million dollars a year
is on board the value of the 11 hours of
his time saved is worth ninety seven
thousand dollars clearly tilting the
math in favor of the private jet the
general phenomenon of globalization has
been great for the private jet market as
businesses need to travel to far-off
places like this especially as companies
outsource manufacturing and other
operations into developing countries
which don't necessarily have much air
service many companies have determined
that private jets are the best way to
get where they need to go but despite
this the private aviation industry was
hit hard by the global financial crisis
and still has not fully recovered well
part of it was genuine cost-cutting
businesses also wanted to show that they
were doubling down on luxuries by
getting rid of their jets even if they
could make economic sense in some cases
it was all about optics and nowadays
these Jets are coming with poorer and
poorer optics for good reason private
jets are truly horrendous for the
environment if one were to fly that
Bombardier global 7 500 the one that
could make it from bentonville to Manila
with just one passenger onboard the jet
would make it only to South Dakota
before that passengers carbon footprint
exceeded that of the average person in
one year increasingly these Jets are
being used for purposes that cannot be
justified economically since 2013
there has been about a 10% increase
among Fortune 100 executives of using
their company's corporate jets for
personal leisure purposes they
apparently justify this by saying that
in case of a work emergency
they might need to get back to the
office quickly and commercial air
service could hinder that firms that
include this as a perk for their
executives according to one set of
research underperform against the market
average in terms of shareholder returns
by about 4% each year of course the real
reason some companies might have private
jets is not because it makes economic
sense because it quite often doesn't
it's because the people who decide
whether the firm will use these are the
very same people that will use them in
many instances the explanation is not
economic its societal now many whenever
Productions viewers are also probably
the type of person who watches a lot of
documentaries if that's you or if you'd
like that to be you you should
absolutely be subscribed to curiosity
stream that's because they have a
library of over 2400 documentaries and
nonfiction titles that you can watch
whenever wherever it's available on the
web
Apple TV Roku Android iOS and plenty of
other platforms one series they have
that I would highly recommend is
innovation nation with Mo Rocca who
looks at new inventions in each episode
and explains these stories behind them
this and the entire rest of true Aussie
tombs library can be accessed for just
$2.99 per month but if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash went over
and use the code went over you will get
your first month completely for free